people underestimate michael there are
plenty of things that he is well above
average at
like ice skating he is a very good ice
skater well the all-star game was three
days away so naturally it was all sold
out the only way scone was getting in
was in a uniform just one problem with
that skarn didn't know a hockey stick
from a slim jim so he went to meet with
the famed trainer cherokee jack
mop the ice
i'm not here to learn how to mop i'm
here to learn how to play hockey
[Music]
[Music]
now take this
what am i supposed to do with this
my
[Music]
well michael scott was quickly becoming
one of the hottest hockey players in the
country you can let go no
okay whoa whoa whoa
yeah i've been pretty much skating my
whole life
i thought about playing in the nhl but
you're on the road so much
you had no time to spend with your wife
and kids
and i really want a wife and kids
each year the national hockey league
accepts one civilian amateur to play in
the all-star game it's down to the three
of you the final test is speed skating
on your marks
get set
die
[Music]
one two
uh my daughter has a skating lesson oh
these all your kids
no just the front too oh hey guys what's
up you wanna go for a ride is that okay
sure cool all right grab one here we go
you ready
hang on tight
all right
we are moving we are really moving now
michael you have to get to that puck
before halftime or the whole stadium
will explode i know it's a good thing my
trainer and mentor is here to cheer me
on cherokee jack michael he died
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one's for you cherokee jack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
filmed this during an actual scranton
high school hockey game they were trying
to qualify for states
that's mine it's great no no actually it
was really screwed up because
they
they were trying to qualify they were
disqualified they'd forfeit the game
undefeated season that's why there were
so many people there
what's this
these are the closing ceremonies step up
um
here on the top one
congratulations to michael because he
closed on his condo so gold medal
i don't
really know what to say
um
not one for making speeches but uh
my heart is very full at this moment
[Applause]
and
for dwight schrute the silver medal
get on up here dwight
[Applause]
silver metal yeah not as good as gold
[Music]
why are you playing the national anthem
oh
cause you're condos in america
[Music]
what the hell is that
those are the doves
[Music]
all right
you